welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
talking about the issues that matter to
you the most
tonight get ready for Rishi Mr sunac
will be Britain's next prime minister
after an incredible turn of events he
secured the votes of more than half of
all conservative MPS but the party
remains divided
what's next for Britain bruised and
battered by these past exhausting weeks
I'm Trevor Phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
Britain's new prime minister Rishi sunak
has pledged to bring his party and the
country together in the face of profound
economic challenge
well the conservatives may want to
dismiss the last few weeks as a fever
dream but it's now time to get down to
reality and the difficult business of
government
as usual our viewers panel from across
the country and indeed across the world
will share their experiences they'll
have their say
and here in the studio
Health Minister and Rishi sunak
supporter the conservative MP Robert
genre
the shadow lead of the commons bangham
debonair
senior research fellow of UK in the
changing Europe and former civil servant
Jill Rutter
and the Times columnist and publisher of
reaction Ian Martin
the big question tonight
Britain's next prime minister are you
ready for Rishi
Rishi sunak is therefore elected as
leader of the concepted body
let's begin as we always do with our
viewers panel and talk to Christine
Christine Robertson in Market Drayton
good evening Christine
what's your good evening what's your
feeling this evening
um I feel like we're witnessing
political deception by the Tories and
the 1922 committee to stay in power and
avoid a general election the Tory party
is split the rest of the country did not
have a chance to vote Richie sunak has
no mandate and we need honesty and
integrity
urgently not more chaos and psychodrama
John uh Christine thank you so much for
that an unambiguous point of view let's
go and see if um we can find another
point of view let's talk to Janet Janet
Cohen who's in Crouch end in North
London Janet
good evening Trevor I am pleased that
Rishi is the new prime minister
he has the Mandate in terms of the
conservative MPS he has the economic
know-how I am happy with a Rishi sumac
and Jeremy Hunt Coalition penny more
Dent was just too similar to his trust
and she even endorsed this economic
strategy
um this is going to be good especially
if you take for diametrically opposed
course to his Predator predecessor
quasiquitain and put the weakest poorest
okay and those who are struggling at the
Grassroots okay with the cost of living
at the Forefront of his policies
by avoiding austerity and embracing
better and enhance public expenditure
especially for schools
hospitals okay Public Service generally
all right thank you very much Janet a
very different point of view let's um
let's go to Paul Johnston
Paul I think you've got a question for
our panel
I I have to have a good evening yes so
um I believe that the conservatives have
become a bit of a shambles and we can't
keep going on like this um too many
changes and we need some stability
um and to be honest that that really
means labor now
um if it was a business it's been so bad
you'd probably shut the business down uh
talking as a business person so my
question is isn't it time for a general
election
thank you very much Paul I I would
normally come in to talk to our panel
before I do that I want to see what what
our viewers panel thinks what the
feeling is in the country as it were
Paul has asked is it time for a general
election
um now we've talked about this last week
didn't we and there was a point of view
which I'll Replay in a second but let's
see what you think tonight those who are
in favor of a general election now or
very soon please raise your hands and
we're going to pan along and see what
we're getting from
we are seeing a lot of hands there I
think last week it was something like 60
40 it looks to me like there are more
people who want a general election now
all right
let's
um put this to our panel Paul's question
is isn't it time for a general election
Debonair why don't you surprise me with
your view on this
of course it's a time for a general
election it's absolutely time for
election because we've had months as I
think Christine and Janet both said in
their different ways of a psychodrama of
chaos but also most importantly people
who've been struggling to see how
they're going to get through the winter
how they're going to manage to both Heat
their homes and feed their families if
they're going to be able to to manage to
pay their rent their mortgage now with
all of that and what's the Tory party
the governing party been doing they've
been fighting amongst themselves they've
been squabbling over who's going to be
the whose turn it is this week to be
prime minister it's just not good enough
we need stability and in order to have
stability we need a labor government the
only way we can do that is to have a
general election okay Robert genre I
don't expect you to say we need a labor
government but what about the general
election I don't think that's the right
answer the conservative party was
elected in 2019 our mandate comes from
that general election and the manifesto
on which we were all elected and what
Rishi sunak said today very clearly is
that he intends to govern according to
that Manifesto and the principles and it
were that we would spread opportunity to
all parts of the country that we would
work to preserve and protect the NHS and
public services that we would Bear Down
on immigration be strong on defense and
I I don't for one minute argue that it
hasn't been a regrettable period I think
it has been as a conservative I'm
embarrassed about some of the events of
the last few weeks there's a big task
for us now to rebuild trust and
confidence amongst the general public I
do think knowing Rishi sunak extremely
well that we now have somebody or will
tomorrow at the helm who is a very
serious person a mature professional
leader for this country who will address
the questions that Christine and others
have already said I'm going to come back
to you and but let me let's just check
with Paul um Paul you've heard what
Robert generic had to say are you
persuaded that this is not the right
time that we've got we should have other
priorities right now
it's definitely the right time
um
you probably won't believe this but I
actually did vote for the conservatives
but I just think
um it's just been such a disaster you
just can't believe a word they say and I
just wouldn't vote for them
Paul thank you very uh Jill Rutter um
we probably haven't been in exactly this
position before but what is the formal
position we don't need a general
election because we've got a new prime
minister but what's happening in the
past no because we've got a
parliamentary system the conservative
party still has a majority of around 70.
so we will only get a general election
if either vicious tunak for some reason
decides as prime minister that he needs
to go and renew his mandate remember we
had those debates when Gordon Brown took
it over from Tony Blair whether he
should go for an election or not
actually in some ways the fact that he
didn't go for an election then was seen
as a bit of a a bit of a sort of loss of
face actually because he's marched
everybody up the hill and then decide
not to call an election Theresa May took
over in similar circumstances after
David Cameron resigned she originally
said she was going to rule out an
election then decided to go go for it in
2017 to improve she thought her position
in Parliament obviously that that didn't
work so there's no necessary thing so we
only get a general election either if
Richie sunac decides to call one or if
things party can persuade sufficient
conservatives that they're so
disaffected and share Paul's view that
they vote with labor in a no confidence
motion and the government faults imagine
them
what do you think should Rishi just say
I want my own mandate I think as you can
see from the strength of feeling tonight
the Tories are going to be really lucky
to get away with this idea that they
don't
have an election such as the the
shambles and the disaster of the last
it's not just the last few few days that
have been very stressful but just what
they've inflicted on the country and for
the last year I do on the other hand
they think that it's a bad idea
immediately now
because I think the international
situation is so precarious and the
economic situation is so precarious that
I don't think
a six-week general election campaign is
a particularly good idea and I think the
country has to I think Rishi sunak is
going to have to level with people about
how difficult the winter is going to be
on the economic front on in terms of the
war and the and the energy crisis but I
think by the time you get to the spring
through the other side of it I think
they will have to hold an election
that's an interesting point though
Robert generic maybe not now but don't
have to wait till
January December 2024 do you
uh the Prime Minister could choose to to
go sooner than that but I think I was
going to concur with Ian that when Rishi
sunak makes his remarks outside Downing
Street tomorrow I think he needs to be
very Frank and honest with the public
about the scale of the challenge that he
faces as prime minister we faces
citizens of the country the economic
context the challenge to the public
finances the stress that public services
are under as they're still in the long
shadow of kovid and I think that's the
message that he will deliver one of
honesty straightforwardness and
seriousness of purpose in trying to
tackle him and and restore public trust
in the government by being seen in time
to be a highly competent and
professional girl all right Stephen
Gilligan I think um Stephen and
Dunbarton
um Robert genrex just
points out that the prime minister to be
will appear on the steps of Downing
Street tomorrow
what do you want to hear from him
well to honestly Taylor I've said
I I'm looking for a general election
and really
I'm looking for some stability some sort
of order
I was asking hey I was pushed when I
voted for a Scenic or modern and just
because it favored the markets I think
for people with mortgages and people are
worried then this would completely harm
the the markets down
this chart was rejected by the party six
or seven weeks ago so let's have a
plaster over a sore it won't stop the
internal bleeding in the Tory party
thank you very much Stephen
um thank you Debonair you know their
support for your positions here but
in reality why would a general election
actually solve the scale of the problem
that Robert generic's been talking about
why now given what's going on
internationally surely a general
election will lead to less stability
rather than more stability well I think
it's going to depend what Rishi Suna
comes up with I think something's been
very remarkable so you're willing to
give him a chance well partly because we
don't actually know what he's going to
do the man has been virtually silent
over the last week or so and we we've
not heard anything from him even during
this official leadership contest I don't
think there's anything he's going to be
able to offer that will bring stability
to this country because he's been part
of propping up a government led by
someone who was shown to have broken the
law and is still under investigation for
mislead possibly misleading Parliament
he did that earlier on this year he has
failed to take responsibility when he
was Chancellor for that emerging crisis
partly caused by Ukraine with it
People's Energy bills I mean I think we
have to look at his track record but
also look at the fact he's told us
nothing about what his plan but you
haven't said why you think it'll make
you told me what the tour is bad but you
haven't told me why generally because we
do have a plan so what we've got at the
moment okay the next prime minister is a
man who's had no plan who doesn't show
any understanding of what people are
actually going through and seems to have
no way of dealing with what they're
going through now kirst armor on the
other hand does all right we have to go
to break this is the great debate up
next the United Kingdom has been
ridiculed around the world over the past
few weeks can Richie sooner repair the
Damage Done to Britain's standing on the
global stage
uh with three prime ministers in just 50
days
the UK's reputation around the world for
stability is taking a battering Rishi
sunak's experience in international
finance may help him but he'll need to
work pretty hard to repair the damage of
the past few weeks he does start with
some unique advantages of course his
appointment has been immediately well
received in India and he's already
secured his place in history by becoming
the first non-white British Prime
Minister though he's also the youngest
since 1812.
now I want to talk to Colette Colette
Osborne in Nottingham good evening
Colette
what's your thoughts this evening
um well I represent the herb Barber and
Beauty sector many businesses across the
UK with the hair barber counts as we're
not regulated no longer the whole the UK
at the moment we're all pulling our hair
out
um this chaos and political party
politics businesses can't afford the
bills jobs are and will be lost and
people's lives are being ruined and
Frank I'm embarrassed to be British I
really am at the moment with a laughing
stock of the Civilized World
um you know I've met Mission myself
um you know as I said last week on this
program if anybody can actually get the
cutting services out the whole of dog it
will be him but what I want to know from
the from the panel and from anybody when
will the government put the country
first in their own personal gain second
we've already put that question oh you
you've had the good fortune that most
people haven't had which is to meet the
the next prime minister did he
inspire you I mean you said you thought
he could he could do the job did he
inspire you with confidence or
there's a terrible gag I'm about to make
uh did he leave you tearing your hair
out as a beautician
well there's a hairdresser look you know
we the thing is it did give me
confidence
um what he did do is something that I've
not seen any politician do yet which is
engaged with our sector and actually
come in a list of small business and I
actually had this conversation with him
everybody says you know he's a
billionaire and he's Rich he doesn't
need to do his job but let's consider
this if he's doing this job
is doing it because he cares and that
really came across to me and so actually
I have every confidence in him to
actually get us out the whole we're in
um you know the Market's rebound today
um as soon as it was announced and I
think anything doesn't work but I think
the only way Rishi will fail is if the
conservative party do not stop their
back biting and this means labor as well
can you all stop and put the country
first please okay thank you Colette
um Robert generick
stop the backbiting absolutely the
conservative party needs to unite around
Rishi now and give him its full support
I think what Colette said was
interesting that Rishi is somebody who I
think you can have confidence in I think
he is a very honest and straightforward
person you saw in the summer in the
first iteration of our leadership
contest Rishi didn't tell the conserto
party membership exactly what it wanted
to hear it didn't say he didn't say
fairy tales about the state of the
economy everything he said in the summer
has been proven to be correct I think
that gives you a sense that he's willing
to say the truth he wants to be an
honest straightforward person the other
thing I'd say is that he is somebody who
I think will represent us well on the
international stage as Chancellor he was
excellent at building links with the
United States and others he created for
example the economic sanctions together
with Janet Yellen his opposite number in
the U.S which has put a lot of pressure
on Russia so he's well known on the
international stage I think we'll do
that one I'm hearing about Rishi Sinex
virtues but but what uh Colette's
question was really about is will the
conservative party stop and this this is
not my language but stop fighting like a
bunch of weasels in a sack well it's got
some of you I've got some of your
colleagues keep saying we want unity and
the next thing they do is bang in a
letter to to uh get the leader to resign
but last week I said that I thought this
was an existential moment for the
conservative party either we handled
this well chose the best person for the
job in the National interest not just
who we would like or who was our friend
and then got behind them genuinely we
have to do that if we don't do that then
we won't deserve to be elected at the
next general election today I saw my
conservative colleagues
applauding rishi's appointment I hope
that that will be followed up in the
days and weeks to come with genuine
support so that we can get on with the
job of governing the country and looking
out for the interests of people like
Colette and her business there's quite a
lot of Applause uh from our viewers on
that but just very briefly in Martin you
you follow this a lot
suddenly is it going to suddenly change
not sure if it's going to change but I
think they now the Tories should really
just forget about the next general
election
and start focusing on the country and
start trying to repair the damage
internationally we now have
terrible image problem internationally
the markets need to be reassured I do
think it's relatively optimistic that
you feel it's not going to be Boris
Johnson lived through that 72-hour
Horror Story of it possibly being the
idea that this lunatic was going to try
and be prime minister again after all
the damage that he's done and sunac is
quite common language
well I'm just astonished that he even
thought that he would try again but you
have someone in police who is relatively
calm technocratic I do think he will
have to have an election at some point
but you know that I think you can
broadly trust him
um to do a competent job at a very very
difficult time uh internationally Jill
there's another part of this whole
operation which is governments are not
just the MPS there are whatever it is
400 nearly half million civil servants
and also public bodies do you think um
Whitehall is breathing a sigh of relief
or is it sitting there in trepidation
thinking what next
well Whitehall likes stability in
ministers it finds it difficult to cope
when you don't know from one week to the
next who's going to be your minister you
like ministers who listen to advice they
don't have to take it but uh but you do
like to think that you've given you a
decent hearing for what you want to say
so that's one of the things that's uh
really important I think actually in
Richie sunac did have a good reputation
from the way he worked with his
officials at the treasury so I think
that's quite a positive he's come in I
think saying quite interesting things in
his statement today about restoring
Integrity accountability and
professionalism and I think people will
be looking for that and would welcome
some of that but I think what you really
want is a United cabinet that can give a
clear direction to the Civil Service
otherwise it's an incredibly difficult
near impossible job to do okay I'm
Debonair that's your worst nightmare
isn't it that they might actually look
competent surely what you like is prime
ministers who are rocky conservative
prime minister I should say who are
rocky who are always in the newspapers
who people think are on their way out uh
Rishi Suna doing what Jill and Robert
generic says would be the worst possible
thing for you
absolutely not we believe in country
first and party second care set that out
uh kirstan with the leader of the day
party at our conference in his his
keynote speech country first party
second is a very important principle to
clear and to us in the labor party and
we do that because we actually want the
country to succeed we want people like
Colette we want her business to succeed
we want it to do well but I think the
proof will be in the pudding as I said
we've not really heard from Rishi what
he's going to do differently from what
he set out in the summer and it is
unfortunately a very different country
now in order to establish our standing
on re-establish our standing on the
world stage there are various things
that he could do we've yet to hear if
he's going to do them I think he could
do well to start by appointing an
independent ethics advisor which the
previous two prime ministers seem to
dismiss as completely irrelevant okay
and I think that's really important I
can answer that ethical heart of
government Rishi has been very clear
that he will appoint an independent
advisor and about time too and so you'll
see that very quickly in amongst all his
Party politics I think it needs to be
understood how serious the situation is
with the markets now what the trust
sites did was to make Britain an outlier
but there are all sorts of problems
across the global markets and that was
just the first explosion so the the new
government needs we all need it to be
successful in terms of restoring some
kind of economic order reducing
borrowing codes
Richie predicted that would happen
you've already seen the markets we spent
an hour on that particular topic I want
to take us to
another piece of um a problem that the
new prime minister has in his inbox and
talked to uh Stephen ferdy whose old
friend of the program in Dumbarton
Stephen
um
I think you've got uh
another problem for Mr cynic
well Trevor I think um as you probably
as you probably know from my previous
um mentions on the program I mean the
Tories have no mandate in Scotland I
mean it's a 10 20 MP we've had a tour
decline Minister we've had since 1955.
um and he has no me he has no mandate in
Scotland it's just more of the same for
the people of Scotland it's going to be
austerity arrogance falsehoods and
contempt for the Waters of Scotland so
you've got a question for our panel
I do I mean in the eyes in the eyes of
the world as the UK looking more foolish
or do we already look foolish
Ian Martin
well I'm you know detecting a sort of
pro-independence uh you know tone to
that question yeah I didn't you need to
be a Sherlock Holmes to get there yeah
and as a as a as a unionist I would say
with respect I'd I hear that concern
about mandate in Scotland but I think
the very last thing that that makes
sense at the moment is to do something
which is 10 times 100 times worse than
trussism which is to attempt to leave
the United Kingdom set up a central bank
use the pound create havoc on the
markets and make Scotland much poorer so
I don't think Independence is the answer
actually I think in terms of Scotland
what seems to be happening is the labor
party is probably coming back and I
think an interesting thing in Scotland
will be if if voters start to get the
idea
you don't you don't always have a Tory
government
inflicted and the the Revival of the
labor party in Scotland may may actually
um spell disaster for the SMP long term
we'll see Boris Johnson made four visits
to Kiev when he was prime minister he
made firm commitment every time to help
Ukraine in the fight against the Kremlin
a little earlier I spoke to the former
president Petro poroshenko to find out
how he's feeling about a Rishi sunak
Premiership he began by paying tribute
to his friend Boris Johnson
first of all Boris Johnson uh is very
great friend of mine and very great
friend of Ukraine and I want to use this
opportunity Boris if you see me on the
TV I wanna we'll make sure he's watching
I hope so and I wanna really grateful
for your efforts since your ministerial
position of the foreign secretary as a
prime minister
[Music]
Unity that to congratulate Mr Rishi
sunak and I absolutely appreciate that
this is the position of the whole
British people
the whole British people supporting
Ukraine
call bipartisan support of the British
Parliament
British government and all British prime
minister because this is war of Putin
not against Ukraine this is the war of
putting against whole free world whole
democracy including the Britain and
during the last statement of Putin he do
not use any more Ukraine he said he is
fighting with the anglo-sax
anglo-saxonian world
and I'm proud that we are part of the
anglo-saxonian world to stopping the
Russian aggressor threw him away from
here and I am a respect of the British
democracy and choice of the British
people and uh for me it is no difference
it is Boris Jones
prime minister trust or anybody else I
am count on the British United Kingdom
and the British people well you will
have to deal with uh Mr sunac if you
were in conversation with him tonight
what would you be saying to him that the
Ukrainian people need and want from
Britain now
first of all I want to congratulate you
second I just wanna remind that Rishi
sunak promise
to pay a visit his first International
visit to Kiev and I know Rishi sunak has
a political leader very young and very
promising political leader who all the
time keep his promises Mr Prime Minister
congratulations with the leadership in
the conservative party in the leadership
of the British government and we are
waiting for you in case please let's
your first visit because this is having
a very important symbolic uh the
importance of the first visit and what
we are waiting from him the leadership
in the world together with the United
States together with the European Union
leadership in supplying the weapons to
Ukraine and I am proud that also my
non-governmental organizations supply to
the Armed Forces of Ukraine and lots of
the uh British uh Army things including
this daf cars this is from Great Britain
the one behind you
and with that situation we're waiting
weapons we wait sanction and embargo we
wait in Marshall Plan second edition we
wait in the global anti-putin Coalition
with the British leadership and we wait
in the future membership of Ukraine in
NATO and sorry about that but future
membership of Ukraine in the European
Union
petroporosenko let's speak to Debbie
Debbie Lenten in Plymouth Debbie
briefly what your thought about where
we've got to tonight
um I'm just surprised that who voted Liz
in firstly was it the same ones who
voted her out
um that's a big shot for six weeks to be
quite honest
you're surprised that could you say that
again please Debbie I didn't quite hear
who voted Liz trust in ah was it the
same people who voted her out
would you prefer if uh if the
conservative party had stuck with Boris
Johnson
yes yeah definitely I think he did an
awful lot to be honest
um he got to say to brexit which he said
he would do
all the covid jobs pretty quickly and
efficiently
and his help with the Ukraine war so
he's had quite a lot to deal with to be
fair
okay Debbie that's that's evoked quite a
lot of reaction from our viewers panel
so I am going to take a test of opinion
now
um didn't expect this but let's let's
see if we can do this
I want to ask who would have liked
tonight to see Boris Johnson heading
back to number 10. let's not worry about
the process but if he had been able to
win who would want to see Boris Johnson
back in number 10 Downing Street this
week those hands up those who wanted
Boris Johnson back
I think I think that actually Debbie you
are in a small but courageous minority
there
about about 10 10
um
Robert genre
was it so implausible I mean uh
prime ministers have come back they've
come back into the they've come back
into the cabinet Alec Douglas Hume came
back after having been prime minister to
serve as foreign secretary
I didn't think it was the right time for
Boris Johnson to return there might be
an opportunity in the future but I felt
that it was wrong to do it now there was
a reason that boris's government came to
an end and some of those issues are
still unresolved including a
investigation by the Privileges
Committee in Parliament I thought it was
better to look forward and have somebody
new in the form of Rishi suneck or be it
somebody with a lot of experience to the
public are comfortable with just to
answer the point that you heard from
Petro poroshenko I do think that Rishi
will take his responsibility to continue
carrying the torch of freedom for
Ukraine very seriously he would like to
visit Ukraine as quickly as possible and
he has been very involved in those
efforts on the economic side now he'll
work very closely with the defense and
foreign secretary on the international
diplomatic yes just ask you a quick
question and you may only answer yes or
no to this did you believe that Boris
Johnson got over 100 votes I was
skeptical okay I have to say I have no
Insight I'll take that as a no let's go
let's go back to Jamie Martin Jamie you
have uh you have a question for our
panel
in Beastie I do gold um yeah to be
honest I'm I'm sick of Pi politics and
yeah the country needs to be put first
so I do want to ask this question will
the Prime Minister put the country
before the conservative party
thank you
um
this is a sort of obvious sitter for you
tangham but honestly you know this
person just speaking not as an opponent
but as a fellow parliamentarian
so what I heard this afternoon when
Rishi made his first speech as the new
leader of the conservative party is that
throughout the speech he used a verbal
device where he spent he talked about
the conservative party first and the
country second and he he made his
priority in that first opening speech
the conservative party I don't think
that's good enough but I'm afraid to say
it's not really about Rishi sunak
anymore it's a revolving door of chaos
and that's not going to bring stability
I don't I actually think that most
politicians go to to become MPS because
they want to do the best for their
country but I'm not seeing that from
Michigan neither did I from any of the
previous Tory prime minister Jill
Russell a non-partisan Observer what do
you think
I think that It ultimately would depends
is the extent to which Richie sunac gets
that actually he best serves his party
interests in the long term by putting
the country's interests first I mean
it's inheriting as Ian keeps saying a
really terrible economic situation
um he's got to start sorting that out it
may be that he's sorting it out and ends
up handing over a better economic Legacy
to the labor party to cure stoma and
that's after all I was a number 10 when
we had black Wednesday John Major then
spent the next five years trying to sort
of restore the public finances to take
his very difficult decisions ended up
handing over really quite a good Legacy
to Tony Blair and Gordon Brown so I
don't think that the two interests are
as separate as this suggests now I don't
I don't think he's going to have any
choice because the stuff that he's going
to have to do is gonna is going to be so
unpopular I mean there are not going to
be massive spending cuts there are going
to be very big tax Rises there's no
other way to do it that's what's coming
in he's going to have to level with
people and tell people that because
borrowing isn't an option
spending cuts won't be tolerated by the
public in terms of Public Services the
NHS welfare there is only one place to
go and that is much higher taxes very
difficult in a recession it's going to
be really tough but he doesn't have an
alternative okay and I I think there's a
big elephant in the room that he's gonna
have to deal with which I want to come
to in a moment but first we'll go to
break this is the great debate some
believe that the last few months have
shown that brexit was a mistake
does that need to be corrected if we are
to see the economy prosper
now one thing that's been striking in
this leadership race is how little the
runners have told us about what they'd
actually do in office this morning one
of the conservative parties donors the
investor guy hands said the economy was
doomed unless the government
renegotiates brexit
so is it time to look again towards
Europe let's talk to Neil redlovich and
Neil you have a question for our panel
good evening travel good evening uh
brexit has been a disaster for the
nation the Northern Ireland protocol the
side of the bus slogan the promises it
will be seamless
the money saved for the NHS a broken
promise of voting new in the Scottish
referendum will secure your EU future
all of which will feel the confer
Edition we have gone from a stable
country to one on the brink of
bankruptcy
so my question is don't we need to
change the brexit deal that was
negotiated by Boris Johnson in order to
move on
thank you very much indeed Neil Neil's
question there do we need to renegotiate
the brexit deal in order to move on Jill
Rutter
not for me to say whether you need to
renegotiate the brexit deal but if you
want to help the economy grow I think
you want to avoid the threat of a trade
war with the EU which means I think you
need to try and find a negotiated
solution to the Northern Ireland
protocol that's what Rishi sunac as with
Liz truss said they want to do but that
will take some compromising and some
political footwork to actually deliver
that but it also May mean facing down
some of the hard-line breakfast in the
conservative party
you could look again and tell them to
the trading Corporation agreement to see
where you could ease things for doing
business and I think if you want to act
immediately tomorrow the commons is
having its second reading of a thing
called the retained EU law bill which
actually would make the Northern Ireland
protocol harder to operate rather than
easier and gives the government really
quite sweeping powers to take a lot of
EU laws off the statute book there's
undoubtedly areas where we can do
regulation better than you did it but
that creates a lot of business
uncertainty the government of course
argues that that bill is a natural
consequence of the decision to leave and
it's just essentially tidying up but
thank you let let me ask you where is
labor on this actually uh I know the
slogan is make brexit work but do you
agree that there should be a
renegotiation for example to get Britain
back into
um what used to be the common market
and well the common market as as a
concept doesn't exist anymore but we
want to make our relationship with the
European Union work and that is how you
make brexit work you do put in the hard
graph that is necessary to sort out
problems with the Northern Iowa what
does it look like at the end well do we
bring down Terraces
to that relationship and the the way we
want to end up is a relationship we have
a strong trading agreement with our
nearest neighbors and partners where we
work with them on areas of mutual
interests such as scientific research
the climate crisis that we're in at the
moment it's shared tackling of crimes
such as terrorism and other threats
there where we've got Mutual areas where
we need to work together sorting out a
way of doing all of those things is
essential and would help improve our
relationships with the European Union
which we are going to need to do if we
want to make things that work which we
will have to do here Martin is that um
possible
it's possible but I you look I voted for
brexit but I think it is a denial of
reality
uh those Hardline brexiteers who say
that it's working and there's no problem
it's clearly a problem is clearly a
barrier to trade and I think the story
of the next 10 years or so
is a story of moving back to a closer
relationship with the European Union I
don't think I wouldn't want to rejoin
the European Union imagine the
renegotiation
imagine the term set imagine the
referendum we don't want to go through
all that again but I think it will fall
maybe it falls to the next Labor
government or maybe it falls to Rishi
sunak who did vote for brexit there has
to be an adult conversation about this
and better trade and better ties with
the EU Robert generick
you can I I don't want to ask you
whether you agree with that I think
she'll probably sympathetic at that
point of view question I want to ask is
this specifically can you imagine
members of your party who have stood out
against virtually any kind of
reproachment with the EU the so-called
Spartans there's two other brothers and
so on and actually agreeing to the sort
of thing that Ian Martin just
spoken of well I'd say it was firstly
quite striking this weekend that Rishi
sunat received the support of Sue Ella
bravaman Steve Baker David Davis Liam
Fox a number of the most prominent
brexiteers in the current conservative
party
I think there is sign of hope that the
relationship between the UK and Ireland
for example has improved significantly
if I interrupt you though they will have
come to that conclusion for a whole
series of reasons what I really want to
ask you is the people who are belong to
the European research group that who
made three years
possibility they will ever agree or
countenance that sort of deal well most
of the people I just mentioned are
members of the European research group
and I think if you look at say Steve
Baker who is a Northern Ireland Minister
he seems to be making considerable
progress on building a more productive
relationship with Ireland that may help
us to resolve some of the remaining
tensions I would like us to have a
pragmatic approach of course we want to
defend the Integrity of the United
Kingdom the ability of goods and
services to operate you know free freely
through the uh Common Market of the
United Kingdom but I do think that could
be done in a pragmatic way and rishi's
election provides us with an opportunity
to build those better relationships five
seconds a rare word of praise for Liz
trust she joined something called the
European political Community which is
dedicated to security cooperation within
within Europe so that's a start okay
thank you very much indeed that's all we
have time for this evening it just
remains for me to say thank you to our
panelists here in the studio thank him
debonair Ian Martin
Jill Rutter and Robert genre
of course it's you at home who are
always at the center of our
conversations and if you'd like to be
part of the program next time you can
get in touch by writing or emailing to
the great debate at sky.uk
and for now I want to thank our viewers
panel thoughtful and incisive as always
thank you so much
and you at home keep talking we'll see
you again at the same time next week for
the great debate
[Music]
[Applause]